that is the greeting of peace and we
wish that upon you
thank you very much for tuning in to the
dean show today's topic you've heard it
i'm sure you've heard this word if you
are a fan of islam and you've heard the
word sharia you might have saw some big
signs out there sharia and you're like
what the heck is this is the boogeyman
coming to get me or what today we're
going to be talking about sharia what
does it mean
what is his definition
how does it
apply and go with islam and how can it
affect you
and we're going to be learning all this
today here on the dean show be right
back
this is
who is the author of the lies about
muhammad
people shouldn't be like it's childish
to lie isn't it yes
it's not good to lie
and
you wrote a book called the lies about
muhammad peace be upon the last the
final message sent to mankind and
inshallah at the end of the show you can
tell people how they can go ahead and
you know
check you up and go and check up this
book which i really recommend for the
people but today we're talking about
sharia yes what is sharia sharia simply
in arabic means law
and it's not the man-made law it's the
law of allah
and here is the significance of that the
significance of the law of allah is
allah who does not need our charity or
our praying or our obedience for that
matter
designed for us the the law and the
manner of life by which we live the most
joyful satisfying fulfilling life on our
way to his utmost price that is jannah
that's the best deal paradise paradise
jannah the best deal that anyone can get
inshaallah now some people you know
again just another misconception they
say jannah all these muslims are
focusing on is the 72 virgins and all
they want is pleasure and you know
they're looking for this party and
paradise and they got to throw a bomb on
themselves what do you got to say about
this well a bomb on yourself is totally
against islamic law suicide bombing is
totally forbidden in islamic law no
matter what the justification is the
number one most punished crime in
islamic law is indiscriminate killing of
innocent people
forbidden there's no more punished crime
in islam than in discriminant killing of
innocent people yet when you think about
it and it's true that there's going to
be 72 versions in all these in paradise
the definition of paradise that every
pleasure that you can possibly imagine
or not imagine is available of it is sex
sex is not a bad thing a bad thing when
it's not done with the wife on earth but
in paradise everything is available for
the wishing any pleasure that you can
imagine is available for the wishing
including sex what's wrong with that
what's wrong with that i mean people
you're in paradise people are lying
stealing they're they're they're power
hungry so they can enjoy the pleasures
of this life isn't it yes you know and
then when you obey god and you never
show harm or hurt to anyone and god want
to give you his reward according to his
ultimate generosity it's everything for
the wishing anything anything that you
heard or not heard but we want to do it
the wholesome way yes now isn't it that
we as muslims those who are submitted to
god isn't the one number one thing on
our mind when we get to paradise to to
have the pleasure of our lord and to see
our lord
beyond all the actually the two biggest
pleasures of a believer of god and when
we say believers of god as muslims we
also talking about the believers of
jesus peace be upon him the believers of
moses peace be upon him these are all
muslims and followers of
the prophets of islam
the two
top pleasures of paradise the number one
is that you're going to be able to see
the face of your creator of allah that
no one was able to see before even the
prophets of god and you're going to hear
the quran recited with his voice amazing
the second thing is that on top of that
with all the pleasures that you're going
to have in paradise that allah asks you
a question are you satisfied and you're
going to say how could that how could i
not be satisfied with all the blessings
from allah
but allah would answer well now let me
give you more satisfaction i will bestow
my own satisfaction upon you forever
i'll never be mad or angry at you and
that is the second best pleasure in
paradise so we should strive for
paradise this life is short and that's
what we want and that's what you
mentioned and we're talking about sharia
now continue on because
is this the boogeyman coming to get you
because they'll hold up the signs people
get frightened they say oh if sharia law
comes now you're going to be subjugated
all your rights going to be taken away
what is sharia community question look
at any law even man-made laws
they're going to be a law that rewards
good doers and a law that has a penal
code that when you murder someone you're
going to be executed in any law there's
two ends of the spectrum even man-made
laws
sharia the law in islam has a totally
different purpose
nothing would explain sharia and islam
more than or better than the verse 157
whatever that is good for you short term
long term whether you're aware of it or
not good for you or good for your
society that god knows it's ultimately
good for you that is what is halal that
is what's allowed for you
and whatever that is harmful hurtful for
you whether are you aware of it or not
for your society or community short-term
or long-term because allah subhanahu
ta'ala god knows that it's bad for you
it is forbidden
and through that you're liberated and
it's the true wisdom of allah the
creator of heavens and earth that tells
you that this is good or bad this is
ultimately good and it's ultimately bad
you follow that you had that one thing
that everyone seeks in the morning from
the president of the united states to
the poorest man what is the right thing
to do sharia tells you and make it easy
for you and guarantees your god-given
rights every single day and every single
moment of your life so can we compare
just just to make some kind of analogy
let's say you have a pot a pan a big
basket you have all these different
herbs and spices and everything some are
good for you some are bad but now you
have an instructional blueprint from the
creator saying use this one it's good
for you this one's leave it alone
absolutely this is the same thing in
life so god has determined what's good
for us the creator not you or me or any
human being but the creator is telling
us this is good this is bad for our own
benefit
absolutely and i give a simple analogy
if i tell you i would have warren
buffett the genius investor to advise me
financially or the best doctor in the
world to advise me about my health or
the best lawyer in the world to judge to
advise me about my law affairs i would
be the happiest man of life imagine if
allah subhanahu wa
creator of heavens and earth giving you
the ultimate advice and for no reward to
allah he does not want anything from you
that's amazing that is that is shania
let's take a break and we'll be right
back with more here on the dean's show
i would go to my room lock the door
prostrate and cry saying god you know me
better than myself show me the right way
and i will not look back i will leave
everything behind
allah is our creator and he creates
everything and it gives intelligence to
people
rasulullah
to bring it home more we want to give
some more examples but tell me now
because many people they know who jesus
is peace be upon him and this is a fact
we love jesus no muslim is a muslim
unless he believes in jesus absolutely
moses also he was one of the messengers
of god who taught islam submission to
the one god along without any partners
did sharia
exist did moses bring sharia ten
commandments was that sharia absolutely
people are like wow you're kidding me
explain no prophet of god that came and
gave a message that that message did not
have do and don't sharia that's god's
law that's god's law yeah and the
purpose of sending a prophet after a
messenger after a prophet is that as
humanity evolved
the message needed to be enhanced on a
need to basis for humanity's needs till
allah sent his last prophet with the
most comprehensive law that is sharia
allah
and that's the ultimate wisdom of allah
to help us and benefit us many things
that some people in the media show about
islamic law or sharia law like you know
they say stoning or this this and that
you would discover that these were basic
fundamentals of the laws of moses the
torah and at the time of jesus be upon
him and people talking as if this is
invented by islam and they do not even
know how it's applicable in islam or
what are the conditions for and this
total ignorance out there that muslims
share their belief in not explaining to
other people but allah is the law and
has been there the message of god is one
all these are prophets of islam prophet
muhammad is the last prophet of islam
this is amazing because i think some
people get a little bit frustrated or
angry because you know we love jesus
peace be upon him but he's not god nor
did he ever claim to be god nor son of
god or any of these things he's a mighty
messenger of god yes and we got the
evidence to prove it and some people
might get a little upset because they
have this attachment to jesus but we're
not trying to offend nobody we're just
trying to relay the truth and let's dial
up let's talk about it so didn't jesus
what we allegedly have attributed to him
he said i have not come
but to fulfill the law i didn't come to
break one of the least of the
commandment the least of the sharia i
came i was sent to bring back the last
sheep to the house of israel the message
of jesus christ upon him was to bring
people back to the ten commandments
after the modifications and the
deviation that some people did sharia
sharia yes ten commandments are ten
items ten paragraphs articles of law
that's what it is i think we need to
just you know ex like we're doing here
and we're devoted to uh helping people
understand because they hear these
arabic words and they get a little bit
bent out of shape because they never
heard the word but when you define you
say ten commandments jesus implementing
sharia you like start to you know calm
down a little bit because you actually
one of the things and actually we need
to clarify that for our viewers at some
point stoning
uh the bashers of islam or haters of
islam would bring stoning and say that's
barbaric this this doesn't that go to
leviticus 2010 in the old testament
stoning go to deuteronomy 22 22 stoning
the famous story in the bible of john
about whoever was without a
sin should cast the first stone what is
casting stones is stoning
islam did not invent that and actually
when you see the mandates and the
conditions that islam applies for that
crime it's impossible to prosecute or
convict one
you know convict anyone according to
stoning the first thousand years of
islam there were only three cases of
stoning and there were adamant
confessions they were not even caught
and scholars tried every way possible to
make these people leave their
confessions and escape the punishment
but they were adamant confessions i made
a sin i want to be punished according to
the law of god in a thousand years a
millennia no one was caught with the law
of stoning in sharia law that people you
know are being scared about examples
give us some more examples so this can
really hit home because when you
implement what god wants you to do not
man or a monkey or anything and create
but the creator if we come to a firm
conviction that the creator revealed
this it's from him it's an instruction
manner from him shouldn't
he be the one who knows best he's the
most why so give us some more some more
practical examples of sharia and how
beneficial it is if implemented
well i go back to the the the main point
you have allah subhanahu ta'ala created
heavens and earth advising you that is
giving you the ultimate wisdom
without you being technologically savvy
or advanced or have the best advisors in
the world example 1997 the american
secretary of health was so happy and
proud that america was the first country
western country civilized developed
country that bans feeding dead animal
parts to life animals why they discover
that that's what causes mad cow disease
and all kind of myriad of animal
problems that can be transferred to
humans and i laughed prophet muhammed is
correct hadith said quote unquote do not
feed dead animal parts to life animals
fourteen hundred years ago two bedouins
who did not know how to read or write
but when you obey the sharia law you
will get the ultimate benefit that
billions of dollars and 1400 years of
advanced research and technology would
give you 1400 years ago in a desert with
no schools and libraries
muslims are banned men
are forbidden to wear gold women are
allowed to wear gold we don't know why a
lot of people say because of vanity but
well my wife is standing next to me
wearing all that gold that's vanity too
i own that she owns that yeah
you know scientists not muslim i want to
add discover that
when you put gold to your skin gold has
this feature that has active particles
that actually go through the puzzles of
the skin and get into your bloodstream
gold as a toxin
in your bloodstream is very harmful it
puts all your hormonal balance out of
whack and it's very harmful for men
and some people would say well women
have skin too what's wrong women has the
what allah subhanahu had afforded him
that they have the monthly course that
discharges all these taxes out of the
body
so allah gives you that 1400 years ago
you obey you get the wisdom that we just
got two years ago
and so on and so forth one of the most
uh endorsed and asked to
do prayer of the day is the first prayer
fresh prayer is like usually five six
o'clock in the morning and a lot of
people say why would i wake and and this
tremendous reward for it scientists
would tell you that if you wake up at
five o'clock in the morning you're 65
percent less
subject to having strokes why you sleep
for straight eight hours your blood
would go up the viscosity would actually
go much higher because the the the heart
is you know your sleep so it's not
pumping that much blood and then
you know clots and you know strokes are
more
so you know possible to happen than when
you actually are walking or running or
doing things like that when you break
your sleep and wake up to prefetch you
just bring your blood levels to the
normal thing so
you pray and you go pray and sleep again
for a couple more hours you are 65
percent less likely to have a stroke or
a clot than any other human being what
drug in the world can do that
you obey allah you get the benefit
fasting it actually triggers the
longevity gene in your body uh but
there's a new uh
uh
product that's called the reciprocal i
think that's advertised all over the
internet that actually a 90 years old
man would look like 60 years of age the
second thing that does that that
activates that longevity gene is fasting
continuous periods of hunger
mandated it's not for the benefit of
allah subhana ta'ala it's for our own
benefit this is sharia sharia this is
the law that god almighty out of his
love he loves us he loves us more than
our mothers our fathers so he wants
what's best for us but can our
perception sometimes of what we think
might be good for us actually be bad for
us what we think what is bad for us
maybe is good for us it's right there in
the quran
you might think that something is good
for you but it's actually bad for you
and vice versa what is the ultimate good
what is the ultimate bad it's in sharia
law and i want to just bring emphasis to
our viewers of the beautiful hadith
prophet muhammad and sahil bukhari he
was standing with his companions and
there was a woman standing there hugging
her baby with love and care you know
breastfeeding the baby and prophet
muhammed looked at them and said you
know what do you think that such a woman
would throw her baby that baby that she
loved so much in fire he said of course
not o prophet of allah he said allah
subhanahu ta'ala your creator is more
merciful and kind to you than that woman
to her own child
that's amazing that's amazing that's
amazing and we're getting to learn more
about the most misunderstood way of life
in the world today islam yet is the
fastest growing way of life in the world
it's the same way of life that was lived
by jesus didn't jesus live islam was
jesus a muslim a mighty prophet of islam
not just a muslim and when someone says
hold on jesus was a muslim
prove it how was he a muslim
practice islam
came to bring about the ten commandments
what is the first commandment god is one
god is one is what makes you a muslim
that's it and obeying the messengers
absolutely if you live during the time
of jesus would you have to worship him
or obey his obey him and he would be my
prophet and i would be a follower of him
and saying that i just want to add the
only non-christian faith that believes
in jesus peace be upon him is immaculate
birth and the virginity and the
greatness of virgin mary is islam the
only holy scripture ever that has an
entire chapter named after virgin mary
is islam
and yet some people come to you and said
you know what he's a muslim his
anti-christian automatically where do
you get that from only
god knows so we're not anti-christ
absolutely not because christ was the
messiah that's what it means christ
messiah and this is the title given to
jesus we believe he was the messiah
absolutely this is amazing amazing
people are learning so much here on the
dean show i hope you're benefiting i
surely am we'll see you in a few weeks
right back
and if we're going to worship something
i figured i might as well worship the
creator instead of any of the creations
now upon investigating all the religions
i remember finding out the meaning of
what islam is what a muslim is those who
surrender their self to god
is a muslim
those who surrender submit to god god's
will
that is it islam was pure it was just
you just pray to god your creators
i am not afraid to stand alone if a lie
is by messiah i am not afraid to stand
alone
i am not afraid to stand alone if allah
i am not afraid to stand alone
i am not afraid to stand alone if allah
is
back here on the dean show and we're
talking about
the creator's law
sharia
and you gave some wonderful examples
and some things that i i'm just
fascinated i'm sure the viewers are the
gold analogy the prayer the fasting and
when you
do it and sometimes you don't know the
wisdom behind it but now someone for the
first time is seeing and hearing the
wisdom you're just even more just
impacted and your faith even rises
because we don't just do blind faith our
faith is based on knowledge yes proofs
and evidences give us some more of these
wonderful actually one of the clearest
examples is that throughout history
if you look at islamic law and have any
knowledge about it as bigger the damage
can be
the punishment is and the warning and
the prevention against is in islamic law
uh people are baffled about and at the
end of chapter two surat al-baqarah that
how allah subhanahu wa such a severe
punishment and warning to people who
deal with usury which is forbidden in
the bible too
eating interest dealing with interests
which people take for granted nowadays
that then will be harable as if you are
waging a war against allah subhana tala
not just disobeying god or angering god
you're waging a war against him and
people said you know this is a part of
business or economy why the punishment
is so severe comes 2008.
they spend so far close to six trillion
dollars to try to bring the world
economy to normal and they couldn't 10
million jobs are lost in america alone
the country of iceland went bankrupt and
the country of greece won bankrupt that
if it wasn't for international aid
people put atm cars in the machine and
did not get cash out and the devastation
of businesses and lives and marriages
and so on and so forth and when you tell
them what happened they will tell you
excessive leverage what is excessive
leverage excessive riba
that god had warned about 1400 years ago
interest yes
god warned us about it absolutely even
in the bible as if you are waging our
world why it's a war against god because
the damage can be as severe and imagine
how much effort you need to do to create
10 trillion dollars worth of economic
activity
gone in a second families destroyed
homeless people business destroyers
countries destroyed countries we are
praying praying now that with all the
efforts that maybe in two or three years
we get back close to the normal
of 2007 after that disaster in 2008.
i just like to make a simple analogy
tell me is this on the money tony
knuckles
who used to be the biggest loan shark
for instance he got sophisticated put a
suit and tie on and now he became a
banker because now you go and you borrow
100 and you gotta give a hundred times
more back you know ten thousand or a
thousand yeah this is corruption isn't
it how does islam how does it work in
islam
totally forbidden if you look at the
roots of slavery in the world aside from
islam before islam it's riba people
borrow money with interest time passes
it's compounded and what happens people
you don't have the money i'll take your
child you become my slave i'll take your
wife and so on and so forth einstein was
asked one day what irish time
what is the most powerful idea or thing
in the universe what was his answer
the one who discovered the relativity
theory and the atomic bomb is it
compound interest wow think about it
it's true this is amazing amazing
amazing so now god is saying one thing
and we want to do another thing but
isn't it now bad for it seems like it's
bad for business now for you know the
few elite that are making the money off
these things sharia's coming god's law
and making a level playing field for all
people entrepreneurship risk-taking you
know hard work is what creates value
money is not does not have intrinsic
value it does not create value you have
to couple that with your hard work and
risk taken and produce economic activity
where people will benefit around you
with the jobs that you create and the
materials that you buy not just you
deposit money in the bank and sit around
and because you're rich you make more
money and more people will get poorer
and work harder just to be at the same
level so islam gives now like the
alternative you don't do it this way
where the rich keep getting richer and
you keep suppressing the poor it gives
an even playing field you said for
everybody and in a nice way not in a
communist way with like richness and
being rich is bad to the contra alley
prophet muhammad said
a muslim that is strong financially
physically socially is a better muslim
and more liked by
god than a weak muslim but be rich in a
fair way that's that's the point that's
islamic law be rich in a fair way be
rich in a fair way and does it show
through history when the muslim when
those who submitted to all the laws of
the creator they submitted their will to
god's will they implemented the
beautiful injunctions that god told them
to implement
didn't this eradicate injustice poverty
all these evil vices listen to this
miraculous example the highest living
standard in recorded in human history
was the living standard of the time of
khalifa omar ibn abdul aziz he's the
grandson of um
and people consider him the fifth guided
khalifa i'll tell you the level of
freshness that they became at
the muslim treasury was flown with money
they went around and said if you have
debts we'll pay it for you regardless
where you did you do the money or how
did you borrow the money people would
not come forward if you want to get
married you'll pay for all your marriage
expenses people do not come forward they
have the money this is islam islam yes
yes
anyone who wants money for any purpose
people did not come forward they had so
much money they had to buy seeds and
throw it
in the desert so the living souls of
bears would benefit from it other than
keep it as money
there were literally no people in jail
find me one country today like at the
time of our analyses that if you
crippled or handicapped by any chance
that the government would assign a fully
paid salaried employee from sunrise to
sunset to take care of all your needs
and you don't have to pay a penny
happiness is not happening today how
much time did he
you know accomplish that
two years
of applying islam correctly real quick
real quick we only have two more minutes
we're out of time tell us now because uh
the argument and we just want to be fair
someone says well how come all the
muslims are backwards nowadays what are
you talking about and the muslims are
the most corrupt this this and that what
do you got to say ask me if islam is
applied correctly or not don't ask me if
muslims
are ruled correctly or not you got
that's the trick you got good and bad
ugly all over the place yes so this is
an ugly example of when you don't
implement islam the example you gave
this is a historical fact when islam was
implemented by the verbatim word of god
the quran and the sunnah the way of the
last and final messenger muhammad
it was the highest level standard that
humanity had ever seen okay this is not
some perfect ethiopia we just conjured
up in our heads it already happened for
years documented you can check this out
absolutely
oh this is amazing thank you uh the lies
about muhammad peace but this is
childish people are you know they can't
beat the truth through through uh
correct dialogue and debate so they got
a lie so you have written a book to
counter all the lies about the last and
final message of muhammad peace be upon
him we're going to get
where can i get this book amazon.com and
barnesandnoble.com and there's a website
for the book itself insha'allah the lies
about muhammad.com the lies about
muhammad.com thank you
we look forward to having you again
may allah reward you in abundance thank
you very much
amazing amazing when you come with a
sincere heart open mind and you come to
the muslims to learn about islam
what do you learn you learn the truth
you don't want to go to to to to hitler
to learn about christianity do you no
you don't want to go to a to to a
a garbage man to learn how to do heart
surgery no you want to go to the people
who know about islam you come to the
scholars the people who really can teach
you the correct way and you're coming
here to the dean show where we got those
people to teach you and you can get
enlightened
and maybe even accept the most
misunderstood way of life in the world
today islam which is
practiced by more over than one point
more than 1.5 billion people all across
across the globe and you got to learn
about sharia which is simply
at moses time it was the ten
commandments jesus called people to
sharia all the messengers of god they
either brought it taught it
implemented it and the last and final
messenger prophet muhammad peace be upon
him who was a brother to jesus to moses
who called people to nothing new he
wasn't the founder of islam but he
taught the same
thing that jesus taught to establish a
direct dial-up connection
with the one god the creator and to
worship him alone and not his creation
and then do the good things that god
told you to do and stay away from all
the
harm all the things that can affect you
in a negative way and this is islam
we'll see you next time until then peace
be unto you come and see what everyone's
talking about if you find one
contradiction it can't be from god
but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best give up
worshipping god is one i will never give
up spending this message i hope that you
take that necessary step you don't know
if you're gonna live until tomorrow
so you got to find that urgency to do
the right thing right now
if you say that you do not believe in
jesus you have stepped outside of islam
you cannot be a muslim is attending our
faith too
it's cold it's late
everybody's sleeping
all the sins i do
i turn to you to forgive my sins and my
heart
on
foreign
um
foreign
foreign